hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to sheltered now this game
is made by team17 and if you don't know
them they made the worms game so I don't
know what this game is entirely about
it's some sort of management thing but
not like a management like a business
management it's where you have to make
sure that your family doesn't die at
least that's my idea
so randomize button boink boink boink
boink boink boink boink boink Oh Jeffrey
no courageous no Dennis proactiveness
not me hands-on maybe
alright I'm a small eater by the name of
Barbara hey Barbara how you doing
apparently I'm violent well that's good
I got all my stats and strength and
dexterity I like it I'm gonna go for it
okay here we go
customize parent - oh that was my momma
oh I thought that was me okay
alright David how's it going you are
extremely well rounded I like that okay
child happy to have it hidden have
inhibit a lady - ha Mary she's
courageous rough-and-tumble men Mary is
strong as [ __ ] she doesn't put up with
her brother's [ __ ] our family name
is Brunel that's name is spike that is a
horse okay I love the fact that our
horse is named Spike but I'm gonna name
our families the IMP Liars
because I'm stupid like that and who you
ought to play the tutorial yes sure I'll
give it a go because I have no idea what
I'm doing
and I don't want anyone out there to
think that I'm ignorant to tutorials
because I'm trying my best and I'm gonna
make sure that this family the apply
spike oh you're adorable
really bizarre but it's adorable okay so
the entire family is down said oh this
is cool
I like this look around the shelter by
moving the cursor to the edge of the
green with the mouse remove the camera
with the arrow keys zoom in and out with
left control oh that's cool I love this
already I'm in love with this it's a bit
early to say that highlight an object
and press the right mouse button to
interact with it the shelter is powered
by a petrol generator okay add fuel do
the generator to restore power so we
need to add fuel go mama Barbara Barbara
is the best I don't know which one of
these I should identify with but I'm
gonna go with Barbara because definitely
not the Sun Stephen he's a little [ __ ]
okay commands will be performed by the
currently selected met family member
shown at the top left of the screen the
generator must be coming okay select
David for this task
Boyd tiring regularly fix items to
prevent them from breaking fix go go
David
you're so handy and well rounded and I
like that Barbara's a rough and tumble
and obviously the daughter takes after
Barbara this icon will appear over any
night of his attorney to prepare got it
okay so he's just gonna torch that with
a blowtorch apparently that's gonna fix
it right up so alright Stephen you
little [ __ ] Steven appliers oh that's a
terrible last name oh god that's awful
I think you need to cycle through SAS
show this character is thirsty red bars
require attention remember highlight an
object impressive right mouse button to
interact with it so we got our water
Bella over here medium water but I love
that this game is right up my alley with
the applier family okay so drink water
from the water but oh there's so many
jokes there but I'm just not capable
enough to make them your goal is to
survive for as long as possible you can
explore its man maintain the shelter and
keep the family healthy to achieve this
explore and gather resources by using
the radio transmitter to set up an
expedition expand the shelter to build
new items from the workbench your next
step might be to explore to build or
check on your family how to survive is
up to you
this reminds me of
60-seconds in a different way but only
thematically and I wanted to say
something about 60 seconds I have tried
many many many many many many times to
record another episode of 60 seconds the
only thing was I didn't want to do
another episode of making no progress so
I was trying to do two different things
I was trying to journal I whoa let me
finish my thought first I was trying to
get the daughter to morph into like the
mutant which helps you win or I was just
trying to meet a win in general and both
of those things are very difficult to do
I didn't want to do it uneasy I wanted
to do it on normal and I recorded and
recorded I tried and tried I've recorded
hours and hours and hours that has not
worked so I am still trying to get that
game to win at this point I think I
might just live streaming and just play
it until I win or until I get her to
mutate one or the other
I am trying I just wanted to let you
guys know I haven't forgotten about
sixty seconds it's just been like it's
like vanish I keep trying it just
doesn't keep working so anyway so it
begins it's just us now together to
whomever reads this in the future this
is our head count
Barbara David Stephen Murray and our pet
horse spike it was lucky we stumbled
across this abandoned war shelter it
seems to have seen better days maybe
with some elbow grease Maurice we can
get into good shape anything is better
from where we came from okay good good
news okay so David let's see does this
need any repair no contamination storage
crate we have very few stuff kill the
rabbit ate the rabbit it looks like we
have the parts to upgrade a system oh do
we is that good eat food need to ration
that food okay Google upgrade wow you
can increase your oxygen shelter's
efficiency by upgrading your oxygen
filter generator or water filter cool
shelter breaches from what that sounds
awesome
level 2 workbench okay
you've just assigned your shelter member
a job jobs appear next to the selected
members portrait you can have a maximum
of two jobs in queue jobs include fixing
repairing crafting eating drinking
showering and sleeping wow I don't know
any of this but that sounds like the
Sims when you queue up stuff for your
sims to do okay Steven you little [ __ ]
what do you need what are you gonna do
okay
little little [ __ ] you get on the radio
and you scan the frequencies I don't
know what that's gonna do I don't know
I'm gonna go ahead and say I don't know
what a lot of this stuff is gonna do I
wish I did but I'm just gonna be trying
through this so if I'm playing poorly
it's not out of ignorance
actually it's 100% out of ignorance but
it's not out of will it willful
disregard it's just I don't know what
I'm doing okay so she needs some food
explain the shelter and build new items
with the workbench okay he's working on
that Barbara you you can let's be the
map you can track your expedition party
some call them back this shelter whoa
that's cool that's awesome oh man
there's so much unknown out there owner
how many super mutants are up there cuz
I'm assuming this was all part of a
nuclear holocaust of some sort I don't
have enough for that so I'm assuming I
need to set up an expedition assemble
your party going on expeditions allows
your shelter members to search the
wasteland for items and resources and
recruit other wasteland survivors to
your shelter you can have as many
concurrent expeditions as you like but
the party size is to maximum let's make
it Barbara and Marie because she the two
of them seem to be good plan around okay
travel on the Waypoint so let's guess go
to I'm feeling the school so let's go to
the school and then hopefully oh oh we
can do all these and then go back home
okay got it got it okay preparation is
the key to successful expedition you may
want to take items to train and equip
other items and weapons for times where
your physical wear fell your welfare is
under threat you equip gas masks to each
party member they might become quite ill
okay so
gas masks to party I'm just gonna take
another gas mask because I don't see all
right okay Marie okay equip that equip
this okay now they're good okay send
party out yeah they're good maybe
they're probably not gonna be good
they're probably gonna die the applier
family's about to have some losses here
yes go on
bye don't die please come back alive and
hopefully with many supplies oh I get it
okay so that's like a two-layer horses
buy these rather rather intense don't
you think okay
oh okay all right goodbye have fun we'll
be here
looks like we have an upgrade system a
shelter member is tired and needs sleep
tiredness prevents them from taking part
of an activity to gain experience so how
do we get them to sleep David how do you
sleep where do we sleep is the question
oh do we sleep no that's not right no
okay water filter integrity is good
integrity is good I guess you could I
guess you could fix that okay so the
kids still on the radio and he's tired
so how do we get him to sleep speed up
time oh jeez someone has got trying to
get in touch and icon important to
answer transmissions okay
so accept transmission all right
searching location is that the best way
to acquire items and resources different
okay hello this is Marie we found a
school out in the wasteland should we
check it out search location yeah check
it out definitely that's why I sent you
out there okay so hey wait going onto
the surface without a hazmat suit can be
extremely hazardous to your health in
order to put one on or the effects of oh
[ __ ] David get back inside you idiot no
cancel that cancel that get back inside
get a hazmat suit then go out there
all right you're gonna get that and then
you can fix this okay so I need to get
David to stop doing that and then he
needs to rest how do I get them to just
not do anything how do I get him to
sleep oh we need to build the bed okay
all right we found something at the
school are you interested examine items
okay you can transfer items that you
find in the wasteland of your carried
items all right in the school Oh home oh
boy okay well let's get some wood we
don't have a mannequin head
we don't have wiring you probably use a
broken radio book stress relief that be
nice magnesium sounds cool ah this
cement sure I guess we should just bring
everything but I know we're gonna have
like I know there's gonna be things that
we can have another place okay we're
done but I don't know what's good and
bad so I'm just gonna take everything
for now okay but Steven you need to
sleep so we need to build a craft item
we need to build a bed they said roll no
that ain't it we need a regular bed
there we go bed all right so we need to
build the bed and we can put it right by
the radio so that we can have someone
ready and ready to go okay so many is
its shower all right you gonna do this
but you are a mature adult you're
practically enlightened so go for it
and then David is fixing up that and
everything seems to be good so
everything seems to be coming up good
enough [ __ ] come on [ __ ] damn it
all right answered the transmission all
right found a small farm definitely
search it up okay so finish resume all
right so he's doing that dory we're good
okay all right what do you okay so burnt
clothes motor that would be good
leather is also good um looks like I
have to drop something
ah but what do we have a lot of we have
a lot of woods so I don't think we need
the wood but this leather sounds good
and the food ration would also be nice
I'm gonna keep that mannequin head I
know it's probably terrible but I'm
gonna keep it anyway just because I'm a
freakin loser no I'm gonna keep the
cement okay there we go I don't know if
that's good but I'm just gonna assume
okay so he's done with that
so you just resume that he's almost done
he can take a nap he'll be good to go
and everything will be but we do not
have a toilet oh god that's gonna be
terrible okay you can move most of your
stuff rearrange shelter in the workbench
okay so that makes sense all right so
sleep oh sweet Babbitt boy he's going to
bed but then he's gonna have to wake up
and go to think oh that's why they can
speed up time okay yeah get up wake up
wake up accept transmission all right
search location right now good a bit
let's beat up time cancel Gilly oke oh
that is a sickly looking elk by the way
oh jeez
okay maybe not okay Frick no okay
obviously get in here but Steven wake up
except the goddammit you didn't get the
transmission [ __ ] ah stupid [ __ ]
yes abandoned could go to bed we need
another bed David needs to eat something
and then he needs to sleeps and we need
to dick over there we are but god damn
we missed the other table we missed the
other option I got like I know there's a
shortcut to selecting him between the
family members but I wasn't a hundred
percent too sure about that just yet
oh there we go okay so they got there oh
they leveled up alright cool
take all well we can't fit the water in
there are you kidding me we can't fit
the water that's no good
okay yes stressed out this occurs when
their basic needs of hunger and thirst
are not satisfied oh boy okay but now I
can actually filter through all my
people he is stressed because he needs
sleep so frickin Steven get the [ __ ] up
David go the [ __ ] to bed and then
Barbara you need a shower so let's craft
a oh [ __ ] good shower we don't need a
good shower we need Oh makeshift toilet
that sounds important
um but I don't know if we can do that we
need a work bench level three before we
do that I don't know if we can upgrade
the workbench just yeah we need rope and
a hint
why is the rope in a form of a noose
that's kind of assuming a lot of things
here I know it's a desperate situation
but we don't need to have that just have
it in a bundle alas oh it could be fun
alright so we need oh we need so many
things Murray needs a shower Barbara
needs a shower but we can't build a
shower until we get more stuff and we
can't get more stuff until we have an
expedition so we need to build what we
can first and then we'll get things
later cuz I think a toilet is gonna be
just marginally more important than good
hiding at this point in time because
whoa this is some stanky people up in
here but it's gonna be even worse if we
got the stank of [ __ ] all over the place
if he looks like we have the parts to
upgrade a system Thank You Murray do we
upgrade and how do we upgrade it oh cool
okay so I don't want you to go out on
the surface but Murray if you could
upgrade the power ah good efficiency
that sounds better but we can't do that
but we can do durable
alright go hammer on some metal plates
onto the generator and hopefully
everything is gonna go ok light dust
storm spike
Oh spike be ok I hope spikes okay out
there so this is this seems like a
problem because we need more beds well
that's what we need
okay so Steven you're sitting around so
craft another room the right there
better hurry up with that you can craft
another room as well craft another room
oh god damn it I shouldn't have left the
cement did I leave the cement I don't
know if we I didn't leave this event oh
that would have been great ooh we can
make more beds oh good good good ok you
can just do that thing so let make a
sleeping bag [ __ ] there's no space we
definitely do that of the room Wow
Steven is going to town on that earth
man I don't I know its survival but
making your children dig a tunnel into
the ground seems like a bit of an
extreme scenario meanwhile David is is
napping his life will be automated
shelter members will take care of their
own hunger thirst toilet tiredness and
hygiene press H or home the switch
automation off that would be nice
good oh man I would need to take care of
everyone individually I don't even know
how to take care of the game properly ok
David you've had enough sleep
get the Frick up okay get get get up you
need to be awake because we need things
to happen you need to go on an
expedition goddammit so just David needs
to go on an expedition by himself I'm
just gonna have him go by itself and I
know I actually know I'm gonna go out
and be unknown cuz I want to see what he
can do with what he's got so take two
bottles of water not just one I didn't
even use the last one and one food and
then off with you don't be gone with you
goodbye
alright so then a makeshift shower
perfect okay I didn't even know that
there was a makeshift shower here okay
so this is good I did not know about
that but that means that they got their
needs there they can get less steak god
dammit
now damn it I miss the goddamn
expedition damn it ah
sassafras oh hi David
welcome back alright he searched nothing
because he did nothing alright whatever
oh god water required holy [ __ ] it takes
a lot of water to go out on an
expedition oh [ __ ]
well dammit I think I may have killed
everybody traumatic experience one of
your shelter members is traumatized oh
no oh no who died trauma
what happened did someone die no one
died traumatized
oh god your stank is so bad I didn't
know spike was dead god dammit Oh can we
at least yes can we get some water
please we need more we need to build
like another water thing a craft item we
need more but water no hey what a
stranger is approach your shelter you
can communicate by answering the
intercom okay David you wanna uh you
want to respond to this one Laura hey if
you're still alive in there I've got
some nice goods available for trade you
want to make a deal sure you can trade
your items okay do they have water there
are items they don't have water
god dammit why don't you have water we
need water a lot of it we need a lot of
water I'll trade you all this [ __ ] all
your [ __ ] for
I don't know I have a mannequin head you
want that it's nice geez I don't have
anything that I want to trade
I guess one radiation tablet would be
nice okay we could do that all right
sounds good enough yep all right thank
you goodbye we're dying
don't mind us we're dying so we're doing
much better on water it like things
actually did turn out okay it was
raining we I'm upgrading the filter
we're fixing we're fixing the oxygen
filter I'm going to have Stephen set up
an expedition with just the kids because
that's the best just the kids are gonna
go out and it's gonna be great okay
they're gonna go to basically they're
gonna go to all this unknown stuff and
then they're gonna come back and it's
gonna be great and they're gonna take
these equip them they're gonna they
don't need any of the other stuff so
they'll be fine they'll probably be fine
so there's a couple of children out
there and then David is gonna be camping
out by the meters so that he knows okay
what you got coffee beans burnt clothes
limestone duct tape okay we're gonna
take the limestone the duct tape leave
everything else okay yes food scrap pile
um water we can take that broken TV I
mean I guess sure if you can haul a TV
all the way back and then that as well
we don't need paint at the moment so
let's just try to get only the good
stuff we get fuel yes I like it
okay TV yeah I guess those would take up
too many spots um I got plastic pliers
ah for the apply shut up okay lens
transistor a [ __ ] let's take out one of
the TVs well actually no the TVs might
actually have transistors so I think but
we can take out one of them for some
sand okay
except okay except examine Oh oh that is
delightful oh that is good oh that is
very good we have water so we don't need
that we can take this the first aid kits
this is wonderful the leather I like it
I like it a lot that's good I'm learning
I'm learning how to play the game my god
okay as soon as I think they're done I
think they're gonna be coming back after
this and then they're gonna all take
care of their needs and everything's
gonna be okay okay this is good saman
and this episode here I don't know if
I'm gonna continue playing this game but
this is actually a lot of fun if I was
um better at it I'd be doing much better
but right now I'm just an amateur but
it's still I love the way that the
universe is out there and you explore it
out farther and farther and I imagine
things are gonna get dangerous like this
obviously is kind of close to 60 seconds
but there's more involved with building
your base that's more involved with
actually going on searching but either
way I don't wanna make a direct
comparison because you know games are
games they're individual things and just
because they're thematically similar
doesn't mean that they're going to be
you know it's fair to compare them but
either way this is a lot of fun I
enjoyed it so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video
no it was still good lies oh cool cool
piece of meat and some spices perfect
exactly what I need